unless you've been living under a rock
for the past weeks you've heard about
this show and I've been watched it all
of it so now I got to talk about it
making a murderer if first of all I want
to give you a spoiler warning it feels
kind of weird to do that for a
documentary series but as information is
given throughout this documentary series
and that information leads you to other
rabbit trails and ties back and other
things I just kind of see them as
spoilers and I'm going to talk about
some of them here so spoiler warning so
making a murderer is a Netflix
documentary series it's about Steven
Avery well Steven Avery's one of the
guys involved in this Steven Avery and
Brendan Dassey a little bit of backstory
here back in the 80s Steven Avery was
convicted of a rape that he did not
commit after he served 18 years of his
sentence DNA evidence comes out saying
hey he did not do it at all so he is
released from prison a free man an
innocent man but the gross Mis handling
of the Manitowoc County Sheriff's
Department that locked him up we're
talking it is fishy as [ __ ] I'm not
going to go over every little detail but
you should watch this series and watch
it this has been the first episode it
leads him to go you know what those guys
owe me some money so he's gonna sue the
county for 36 million dollars the
insurance isn't going to cover it
because they were all slime bags so the
sheriffs themselves are going to be
responsible for that money and three
days before this all goes down a girl
named Teresa Halbach ends up missing so
they hone in on Steven Avery's are like
oh he must have done it so now he is on
trial for murder and this is where the
spoiler warning comes in he was found
guilty he's going to spend the rest of
his life in prison without the
possibility of parole what this
documentary does it shows us how the
investigation and the trial was carried
out and it is baffling it being a
documentary everything and here is
footage it's all courtroom footage
police footage news footage there are no
reenactments there are no actors
betraying the people it's all what you
see is what you get all of it you watch
it you're like I think this guy might
have wrongfully gotten [ __ ] out of his
life clearly this documentary series is
one-sided it was made by people who
believe Steven Avery to be innocent so
they want you to see that side of it
that being said from what I saw in this
documentary series there is a fair
amount of reasonable doubt still there
in which case you can't just say the
unreasonable doubt that Steven Avery
must have done this crime there's some
fishy [ __ ] involved
I'm not going to go over all the details
that would literally they would take me
10 hours because this series is 10 hours
long but it really is fascinating how
most of this [ __ ] happen I mean even in
this murder investigation he now has a
conflict of interest between him and the
Manitowoc County Sheriff's Department
you know the ones he was suing in the
Manitowoc County Sheriff's Department
they were big on this investigation they
were a big part of it a conflict of
interest a lot they should have just
been left out of it entirely but they
weren't and of course they found most of
the evidence which that was part of
Steven Avery's defense it's like he's
being set up by the Sheriff's Department
was he again don't know Steven Avery's
blood was found in Teresa halbachs car
her car was found in his junk yard not
even in the back of the junkyard we're
talking close to the entrance of the
junkyard without ruining it for you
there is a scene in here it's one of the
holy [ __ ] moments that shows the
Manitowoc County Sheriff's Department
could have had and used Steven Avery's
blood it's one of those cliffhanger
endings you're like I can't believe this
[ __ ] and that brings us to the other
person who got boned [ __ ] out of a
life in this entire thing and that's
Brandon - Brandon Dasia Steven Avery's
nephew he's mentally slow he has like an
IQ of 60 something or 74 perspective
Forrest Gump had 75 so he's a simple 16
year old kid these two cops get ahold of
him and interrogate the [ __ ] out of him
his mother's not present it's just them
and these cops strong I'm the [ __ ] out
of him until he confesses to this murder
the thing is he's saying nothing
happened I didn't do anything nothing
happened - like now Brandon we need you
to confess and when you confess we can
help you so what happened nothing
happened
Brandon that's not the truth we need the
truth what happened you killed that girl
didn't you
this was on and on and on - were there
like something happened with her head
she was shot in the head something
happened with her head Brandon what you
could see the gears returning because
these two cops seized authority figures
want something from him they're saying
we can help you if you give us this so
he really wants to help them so he's
like we cut her hair they're like no
Brandon something else with her head
what happened with her head we punched
her in the head and finally one cop gets
so frustrated he's like okay who's shot
her in the head and then he's like he
did like okay well that's your
confession and now you're going to
prison for murder and to give
perspective
Brandon is mentally like a child if you
saw two adult cops doing that to a child
that
infuriate you it should be no less
infuriating here Brandin statement makes
no sense either in this interrogation
like what happened what happened they
keep pushing and his story is changing
the story just builds because they don't
have and they don't have what they want
so Brian is trying to give them what
they want in that he is making this
outlandish story and it's the lack of
evidence corroborating Brandon's
confession is part and partial wives
like net that just didn't happen not
only do you see these cops strong-armed
this fabricated story out of this kid
but the evidence just doesn't back it up
there's her blood is nowhere in the room
but in the garage they found a 22 round
a bullet with her blood on it here is a
scenario I'm gonna throw out there if I
am thinking of scenarios if if the cops
found the van found her dead and wanted
to just pin it on Steven Avery they had
her blood because her blood was in the
van what if they took her blood and put
it on a 22 bullet that was in the garage
these are backwater Hicks right in the
middle of nowhere in the middle of
nowhere
you shoot 22 at soup cans and Chevy used
to do that all the time it would be an
easy thing to do and I only throw this
out here because her blood is nowhere
else in this messy ass crappy garage if
you shot her in the head blood spatter
would be everywhere on a bunch of [ __ ]
they bagged and tagged every little
knick-knack in this messy ass garage her
blood was on nothing are you telling me
that simple jack with an IQ of 70 spot
cleaned all the DNA from the bedroom and
the garage Dexter Morgan couldn't do
that [ __ ] it's just it's too much for
him to do unless he knows Winston wolf
from pulp fiction I can't buy it again
with that reasonable doubt that [ __ ] is
there as for the theory that the
Manitowoc County Sheriff's Department
could have had Teresa halbachs vehicle
before it was found in Steven Avery's
junk yard actually put a link below for
a YouTube video that's like a three
minute long scene from making a murderer
watch it and tell me what you think was
Steven Avery was serving 18 years for
the rape that he didn't commit there was
actually something that came forward
that absolved him of that crime before
the DNA evidence actually did Manitowoc
County Sheriff's Department was like
okay click and they did nothing about it
they've been corrupt before so I see no
reason why they couldn't be corrupt now
there's no trust there goes in the end
making a murderer is fascinating
one-sided absolutely
but fascinating it shows the flaws of a
justice system it shows how when you go
into a trial with tunnel vision like
this guy did it you don't want to see
anything else you're going to see
exactly what you want to see and I'd
suggest watching it for nothing else
don't leave it at the documentary look
into the trial look into the evidence
look into things I don't know I just you
start googling stuff you're like I want
to know more about this I make no
mistake although I talked about some of
the evidence in this video and some of
the fishy situations it's tip of the
iceberg kind of share me there's more to
see in this show if you watch it so
making a murderer have you seen the
series what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more